se io non sono per me Chi è per me
Ma se io non sono per gli altri chi sono
io e Se non ora quando
Questa è famosissima riflessione del
maestro il ci introduce uno delle
domande fondamentali della nostra
identità Chi siamo noi per gli altri
le nostre identità Innanzitutto non va
confusa con i mezzi che noi utilizziamo
per dimostrarle Per darne dimostrazione
carte d'identità passaporti le
credenziali che utilizziamo per
consultare la nostra posta elettronica
sono solo mezzi per provare le nostre
identità non sono la nostra identità
nostra identità ha tanti aspetti uno è
quello delle nostre identità civile Chi
siamo noi per le istituzioni della
nostra collettività
la nostra i nostri dati anagrafici lo
stato civile i dati catastali degli
immobili che possediamo se ne possediamo
fanno tutti parte della nostra identità
civile chi siamo per la collettività e
sono conservati presso le pubbliche
amministrazioni poi c'è una nostra
identità biologica o sanitaria i dati
relativi agli accertamenti diagnostici
che abbiamo effettuato ai farmaci che
assumiamo il nostro stato di salute e
sono tutti dati che sono conservati dal
servizio sanitario nazionale o dalle
altre istituzioni che tutelano la nostra
salute e poi c'è l'identità finanziaria
banche Assicurazioni società finanziarie
conservano informazioni Relativamente ai
nostri rapporti di debito credito il
nostro patrimonio mobiliare e in
particolare le assicurazioni conservano
informazioni su certi eventi
significative della nostra vita che loro
chiamano sinistri
parlando sempre di identità finanziaria
C'è poi la centrale rischi presso la
Banca d'Italia che forse non Tutti
conoscono è una un ente un'istituzione
che ha lo scopo di raccogliere le
informazioni sul nostro status di
debitori se qualche volta avete saltato
una rata del mutuo probabilmente la
centrale rischi lo sa e lo possono
sapere anche tutte le istituzioni
finanziarie che sono legittimate ad
accedere a queste informazioni
ora questi sono alcuni aspetti della
nostra identità del nostro essere per
gli altri ce n'è un altro molto
importante la nostra identità
commerciale Le nostre abitudini di spesa
le nostre rapporti commerciali che
intratteniamo con gli enti con soggetti
on-line e anche con soggetti come
supermercati che dove invece facciamo i
nostri acquisti e portiamo a casa
fondamentalmente le nostre le cose che
ci servono per la nostra vita
tutte queste cose voi Mi direte sono non
sono un'invenzione recente sono sempre
esistite sempre No diciamo che le
istituzioni civili le banche le
assicurazioni esistono da molto tempo
anche il negozio dell'angolo il
salumiere dell'angolo esiste da molto
tempo e in un certo senso
conservava informazioni sulle nostre
abitudini di spesa in modo da poterci
servire meglio già da molti anni perché
tutte queste cose oggi le chiamiamo
l'identità digitale
perché nel frattempo è successo qualcosa
di relativamente inaspettato E
soprattutto è successo in un tempo
brevissimo Abbiamo acquistato in meno di
20 anni 30 anni la capacità di
memorizzare elaborare e soprattutto
comunicare da una parte all'altra della
terra tutte queste informazioni senza
dimenticarne alcuna più di tutto Abbiamo
imparato sviluppato dei metodi
matematici capaci di correlare queste
informazioni
al punto che oggi
i soggetti che dispongono di queste
informazioni hanno o possono avere una
conoscenza della nostra identità
addirittura superiore alla conoscenza
che abbiamo noi perché questi metodi
matematici permettono di estrarre da
questa Massa informe di informazioni
pensate ogni minuto vengono prodotte più
informazioni di quanto erano contenuti
nelle storiche biblioteche di
Alessandria Ecco tutti questi soggetti
hanno la capacità di estrarre una
conoscenza che è latenti in quelle
informazioni ma non è evidente quindi
chi sa farlo chi può farlo Chi è i mezzi
e necessari mezzi importanti di calcolo
alla capacità di estrarre più
informazioni di quante noi stessi non
conosciamo
tutto questo non è male non è di per sé
male
Pensiamoci bene se la pubblica
amministrazione conosce meglio i
cittadini può fornire dei servizi
migliori
pensate soltanto alla precompilazione
della dichiarazione dei redditi la
stragrande maggioranza dei cittadini
italiani non ha posizioni tributarie
particolarmente complesse e il fatto di
poter schiacciare un bottone assolvere i
suoi obblighi tributari in poco tempo è
sicuramente un vantaggio ma questo nasce
dal fatto che informazioni in possesso
della pubblica amministrazione vengono
utilizzate in questo caso in favore dei
cittadini lo stesso discorso vale per le
istituzioni per le istituzioni sanitarie
le istituzioni sanitarie possono erogare
servizi migliori soprattutto a livello
di prevenzione conoscendo una migliore
stato di meglio lo stato di salute dei
cittadini
per le situazioni finanziarie Il
problema è più complesso perché una
miglior conoscenza da parte delle banche
per esempio della situazione
dell'identità dei loro clienti potrebbe
limitare l'accesso al credito da parte
delle fasce più deboli d'altra parte le
banche sono in larga misura e
istituzioni private Non è compito loro
Temperare le disuguaglianze è compito
dello Stato che con altre norme altre
leggi può intervenire in questo senso
purtroppo il problema più grosso legato
dalla nostra capacità di elaborare dati
non viene da chi rielabora
legittimamente Ma dai possibili abusi
che potrebbero essere commessi in questo
senso Quindi da qualcuno che
indirettamente ovviamente in modo sul
rettizio riesce a impossessarsi di
questi dati e grazie a questi dati viene
a conoscere un pezzo della nostra anima
perché la nostra identità pubblica è un
pezzo della nostra anima
conoscendoli Può condizionarci
direttamente può anche condizionarci
indirettamente magari rubandosi la
nostra identità Quindi presentandosi
come noi ad altri Il problema è che
tutto questo sconvolgimento è avvenuto
in così poco tempo molto meno della vita
di un uomo da non darsi tempo di
imparare dalla nostra esperienza oggi la
maggior parte di noi non ha esperienza
di quello che potrebbe succedere grazie
a queste manipolazioni e cade proprio
per questo vittima di Inganni di truffe
e di altri abusi che dobbiamo cercare di
prevenire faccio qualche esempio
le truffe online spesso utilizzano
informazioni
acquisite pubblicamente disponibili e
acquisite da soggetti di questo tipo che
vogliono abusare dei nostri dati e
agiscono spesso con lo stesso schema
qualcuno si presenta come nostro amico
ci sottopone un problema ostentando una
conoscenza nostra o di nostri conoscenti
molto accurata
Dopodiché dopo averci ingannato e averci
convinto di essere nostro amico di
conoscerci bene ci propone una soluzione
e ci dà poco tempo per decidere gli
schemi delle truffe online il nostro
esempio sono sempre gli stessi io tu hai
un problema Io ho una soluzione ma non
abbiamo tempo per per procedere quindi
dobbiamo farlo subito Ecco Ricordatevi
che in tutti i casi reali il tempo non è
un problema Ci sono giorni settimane a
volte mesi per correggere i problemi che
possiamo incontrare nella nostra vita
civile subito è competenza del Soccorso
pubblico Semmai vi capitasse chiamate il
112 sono gli unici che vi possono dare
un'indicazione in questo senso
per i problemi di altro livello cioè gli
Inganni collettivi questi nascono dalla
conoscenza della psicologia collettiva
che deriva dall'analisi dei grandi masse
dei dati e abbiamo avuto esempi anche
nel recente passato di condizionamenti a
livello di campagna elettorali in altri
paesi proprio legati a questa conoscenza
e allo sfruttamento di paura recondite
delle persone o di desideri reconditi
non tanto reconditi a volte proprio per
condizionare l'esito elettorale che è un
gravissimo problema per le democrazie
liberali come noi le conosciamo ora
possiamo fare qualcosa per porre rimedio
a questo tipo di problemi Certamente
Dal mio punto di vista cercare di
opporsi al trattamento dei nostri dati
in modo generalizzato è una partita
persa Prima di tutto perché i dati
vengono comunque trattati secondo perché
chi li tratta legittimamente magari si
troverà in condizioni di non poterci
erogare i migliori Servizi chi li tratti
illegittimamente continuerà a farlo
perché ovviamente non deve rispondere
sicuramente di queste nostre
preoccupazioni
la nostra il nostro compito è quello
senz'altro di chiedere alle pubbliche
amministrazioni alle istituzioni
sanitarie alle istituzioni Finanziarie
di trattare in modo lecito i nostri dati
e trattarli soprattutto a nostro
vantaggio perché Ricordiamoci che i
nostri dati sono solo nostri non di
nessun altro chiunque li tratti
legittimamente li tratta per nostra
gentile concessione con il nostro
consenso ed esclusivamente per fornirci
un servizio che noi abbiamo chiesto o
comunque per un utilità collettiva Come
può essere la ricerca scientifica che
viene comunque a nostro vantaggio
purtroppo nessuna norma può impedire un
abuso una norma può soltanto sanzionarlo
ma per sanzionare un abuso servono degli
apparati investigativi e repressivi
estremamente costosi noi non abbiamo
tutte queste risorse soprattutto dal
punto di vista umano meglio investirle
in parte Certamente in questi apparati
ma meglio investire Nella formazione
meglio investire nella scuola meglio
investirle in tutti quei sistemi di
istruzione che possono mettere i
cittadini come me come voi in condizioni
di riconoscere questi problemi a cui non
siamo abituati
ricordate Ci sono poche semplici regole
almeno al primo livello se qualcuno si
presenta dice Tu hai un problema io ho
la soluzione non abbiamo tempo è una
truffa al 100%. se qualcuno vi chiede
informazioni
per erogarvi un presunto servizio
correggere un presunto problema
probabilmente una truffa perché le
istituzioni che possiedono i vostri dati
li possiedono già non hanno bisogno di
chiedere queste informazioni al massimo
vi dicono abbiamo scoperto un errore
questa è la soluzione fine non ci sono
altre cose e per quel che riguarda tutte
le cose che sentite e che vi sembrano
troppo belle per essere vere ricordate
che o non sono belle o non sono vere
un'ultima cosa
non ho volutamente trattato questo
aspetto prima c'è anche un aspetto
importante della nostra identità e
possiamo chiamarla identità sociale o
memoria sociale
la rete non dimentica nulla quello che
noi pubblichiamo le fotografie i
commenti restano lì per sempre
Non c'è modo di eliminarli anche se si
parla di diritto all'oblio tecnicamente
ci manca questa possibilità possiamo
soltanto enunciarla ma non potremo per
il momento non potremmo attuarla quindi
si dice che
chi ignora La storia è condannato a
ripetere negli errori e gli errori e
questo è certamente vero a livello
collettivo a livello individuale le cose
sono un po' diverse la rete non
dimentica ed è lì per ricordarci tutti i
giorni anche le cose che noi vorremmo
fossero dimenticate ma soprattutto le
cose che noi vorremmo dimenticare i
torti subiti le ingiustizie patite o
commesse
Tutti gli amori non Nati o finiti male
tutte le primavere che non sono
diventate stati la rete non dimentica
quindi impariamo a farlo noi
ricordate le parole di Friedrich
Nietzsche
Beati coloro che dimenticano perché la
faranno una buona volta finita con i
loro stessi errori Grazie